[Music]
yeah Chuck this is Bravo one we still
have a chance to grab some here good
[Music]
you can run but you can't hide that's a
scene from the new CBS drama SEAL team
which premiered last night the military
series follows the personal and
professional lives of a group of Navy
SEALs as they train for plan and carry
out risky operations around the globe
Carter Evans went behind the scenes to
show us how some former members of the
military special operations forces
helped guide the cast and the crew in
CBS's new drama SEAL team the military's
elite are put to the test
tackling dangerous undercover missions
abroad
and life at home and I realize it's a
long shot but you're great if you could
come by one evening it's the first week
of new rotation
it's the latest project for Star David
Boreanaz he spent nearly a decade
playing a vampire in the popular series
of Buffy the Vampire Slayer why are you
following me don't worry I don't fight
and it's spin-off angel and most
recently he starred as an FBI agent in
the long-running TV hit bones this is so
different than everything else that you
have been doing tell tell me what the
challenges are it's tough when you when
you look up to these seals and
understand what they do I didn't fully
understand what these guys did and when
I when I signed on it became more aware
[Music]
to tell the story of one of the
military's most covert units the show
partnered up with real-life former
members of the Special Forces
the majority of our time has been spent
in the writers room crafting stories
former Navy SEAL Mark seamos and former
US Army Special Operations soldier Tyler
gray
offered their guidance on and off-screen
what we're trying to do as a group is
make something that's not real obviously
but make something that's authentic and
that feels authentic so we basically are
coming in we visited the cast as they
prepared to shoot a scene in which the
seals try to rescue a group of hostages
on a boat captured by terrorists the
show
also explores life outside the
operations something gray a nine-year
military veteran knows all too well even
when I'm in a scene it's like the
skillset that I worked on for so long
like where do you go with that where do
you go now I get to use it a big problem
that a lot of people have is finding an
outlet for it and this is my outlet
we're all trying to find balance we're
all trying to find heroes if we can show
that these heroes can be heroes but
they're humans they're people just like
the rest of us that's what we want to do
talk this is Bravo for 11 hostages
secured for CBS this morning Carter
Evans Los Angeles the boy really is an
idea that the seals have taken a whole
in terms of the sort of the American
imagination people are fascinated by the
Navy SEALs who they are what they do and
how they do it no meant middle and
physical toughness and and the risk that
they take on parachuting into a place to
accomplish a mission and hopefully come
back and so to see the humanity I'm
looking forward to it I had the
elaborations when I was a little girl
believe it or not wouldn't last a second
in the seals but I think you would have
done alright but better you're here yeah
better than I watch it yeah at home on
television and you can watch seal team
on Wednesday nights at 9:00
Central right here on CBS you can also
catch up with the series on CBS all
access and video on-demand